Good morning Hank, it's Thur- what? What is
today? What? It's Wednesday, January 9th?
10th? 10th. Boy, I'm out of it.
Hi girls who are being used as objects to
sell other objects! Sorry about the patriarchal
oppression. Good luck selling Dodge Caravans!
I was inspired by your video blog yesterday
to calculate my own carbon footprint, so,
um, I'm gonna go to BP.com and do it, and
then it's gonna be pretty boring so I'm gonna
speed up the tape.
("Union Maid" by Old Crow Medicine Show plays)
Hank, I produce 16 tons of carbon a year.
That is lower than the United States average
of 18.58, but it's still really bad. Sixteen
tons of carbon would fill three Olympic-sized
swimming pools.
Global warming solution idea: What if we took
a lot of Olympic-sized swimming pools and
we filled them with carbon and we shot them
into space? Wouldn't that work? Can you shoot
an Olympic-sized swimming pool into space?
Is there a way to condense the carbon dioxide
into swimming pool-sized shapes? Anyway, I
think this could work; I don't understand
why no one thought of it before.
I just read on the internet that it only costs
six dollars per ton to get rid of your carbon
footprint. Uhh, that means that it's only
gonna cost me, like, I'm not very good at
math, hold on, I'm gonna call Daniel. I dunno,
he's not answering, maybe he's doing real
math. *sigh* Hey, how's it goin? Is 21 minus
eight fourteen? Oh, this is one of those this
is one of those, like, abstract math jokes.
It's funny you should say that because I'm
actually recording this on a video blog right
now because I have a question for you. What's
sixteen times six? It's 96. Do you see how
fast he did that? He doesn't have a calculator.
96. $96 a year, that's what it would cost
to offset my carbon consumption. Or my carbon
production or whatever.
If I pay Al Gore $96, I will not have any
global warming attached to my name. I think
you can pay him directly, I think you just
write him a check, and he just takes care
of it.
He does, he eats the carbon. That's exactly
right, that's how he does it, he eats the
carbon. And then when he poops it out, it's
actually political gold.